mon bureau de la vision l'appartement
une journée d'installation dans la bonne
humeur une semaine après l'incendie le
maire de la commune intègre son nouveau
bureau on se trouve ici dans la dans une
aile de la résidence pour personnes
âgées avec on a essayé de séparer les
résidents qui sont dans la partie avec
les restaurants etc et là on a récupéré
les appartements des concerts ou qui
servaient également aux activités et à
l'étage on verra 4 chambres un
déménagement temporaire dans une aile
inoccupée de cette résidence appartenant
à la commune installation de mobiliers
d'équipements informatiques toute
l'équipe municipale s'est mobilisée ces
cinq derniers jours ce matin dans ce
lieu insolite les agents reprennent le
travail avec soulagement
super vue une cuisine par bureau ce qui
on va pas dire c'est du luxe mais
presque on aurait pu avoir un défaut et
ne pas avoir de local pour se
réinstaller là en une semaine voilà on
est dans de bonnes conditions un rebond
après la sidération dans la soirée du 29
juin dernier plusieurs individus brise
la porte d'entrée de la mairie avant d'y
lancer un jerrican d'essence le feu est
rapidement circonscrit par les pompiers
bilan des dégâts un hall d'entrée ravagé
par les flammes et des bureaux à l'étage
dévastés par les fumées
on sent bien que c'était une espèce de
guérilla pour pour mettre le trouble y
compris dans les petites communes
aujourd'hui moi les habitants comment
vous avoir peur quoi parce qu'ils se
disent pourquoi pas demain l'école moi
j'habite au-dessus voilà ça va être ça
va être un peu la peur dans la vie quoi
même dans les petites villes évaluer à
plus de 800000 euros les travaux de
remise en état devraient durer un an une
période durant laquelle le public lui
sera accueilli à quelques mètres de là
dans les locaux de la Maison Française